The Hunger Games Mockingjay part 1 now
if you guys have been following my
reviews for a few years now you would
have known that I admired the first
Hunger Games movie really surprisingly
Awful's the loved Catching Fire and I
was excited for this movie because it's
directed by the same person
the first movie had a lot of shaky-cam
which really unnerved a lot of viewers
but the second film is directed by
Francis Lawrence it was Swift
it was fluid and it was really well
directed and he is taking over the reins
for Mockingjay part 1 which was really
exciting for me and this film continues
a story of Katniss played by Jennifer
Lawrence and a group of rebels who are
going up against the evil Capitol that's
been reigning over them with death and
chaos and evil evil stuff for a long
time no way Catching Fire ended you were
like yes let's just see them just go
against the Capitol yes if those guys
they suck their shitty people go kill
him yes
so for Mockingjay I was really pumped to
see that happen this movie is based off
of one book however and it's being
stretched into two movies which is a
trend nowadays the Twilight films did it
the Harry Potter films did it and now
the Hunger Games movies are doing it and
even The Hobbit movies are doing it one
book for three movies so I was really
optimistic going into this movie I
wanted to like this movie and
unfortunately this movie should have
been called The Hunger Games Mockingjay
part 1 the extended trailer for a
hundred years Mockingjay part 2 now I
want to make one thing really clear for
The Hunger Games fans out there and for
the people who are fans of me who really
wanted me to like this movie this is not
a terrible movie this is not what I
would call a bad movie it is a movie
however where nothing really of interest
happens until the last 20 minutes or so
like imagine if the Mockingjay novel was
a rubberband and he just took that
rubber band and you kept stretching it
and you kept stretching it and he kept
stretching it eventually it's going to
break they're trying to stretch the
events of that book over to movies and
with this film when it comes off as
grasping for the tiniest little bits of
details that don't really add anything
to the movie-going experience that
really actually take away from it and
make it kind of tough to get through
because there really isn't much of any
action in this movie at all and when I
say there isn't any action in this movie
I'm talking there really isn't much
action in
the movie at all the shot they promoted
so often the trailers of Katniss
shooting an explosive arrow at a jet
that's really the only thing she does in
the movie of an offensive nature the
majority of the movie is actually a
camera crew filming commercials with her
propaganda pieces to encourage the
soldiers in their revolt against the
Capitol and that really is most of what
she does in this movie Jennifer Lawrence
is a fantastic actress and her character
is very interesting and she gives a
great performance once again in this
movie in fact all of the acting in the
movie is very good a lot of the drama is
really well done there isn't one thing
in the movie that you would pinpoint and
go that is really bad but one of my main
issues with the movie is actually the
character of Katniss I feel that she
does not grow in this movie at all I
feel like she's the exact same character
she was in the last one there's no
growth in her as a character in this
movie I don't feel that she's matured or
really learned much of anything in this
film and for that reason she became less
interesting around a story that was even
less interesting that is filled with
endless political motivational speeches
like take the scene in Matrix Reloaded
where Morpheus gave that motivational
speech at the rave and then times that
by 10 and you got all that in this movie
except without the rave part just the
speech part candace as a character does
not grow at all she's the same as she
was at the end of Catching Fire but she
doesn't use any of that any of that
thrill that you got of her rebelling in
this movie nothing really happened she
gives motivational speeches for
commercials that are filmed for
propaganda purposes she sees a lot of
dead bodies and cries a lot and stays
underground for the entire movie nothing
happens in Mockingjay part 1 the
characters that are interesting don't
get to do anything interesting they just
sit around and talk and give speeches
and it's not until the last 20 minutes
of the movie that you feel that anything
of Merit is actually happening and you
feel like okay am I about to watch the
actual movie and then it ends in the
first film the shaky-cam was so
abhorrent and awful I couldn't stand it
so it was great to see Francis Lawrence
take the reins of the second one and
make a much more smooth film
unfortunately in this one some of the
shaky-cam is back I don't know what the
hell he was thinking when he decided he
wanted to follow people running
with a shaky handheld cam hasn't this
series got enough flack for that and
didn't he fix that with Catching Fire
I'm really confused guys I'm sure I'm
coming off as hating this movie but it
is a well acted movie it does have
potential but it's filled with
potentially awesome things that never
reach their arc and I was worried that I
was like the only one I was feeling this
way but I would say like five six seven
people all came up to me and were like I
almost fell asleep and that is a true
statement because I nearly nodded off
halfway through this movie this is a
really easy way to describe a
not-so-great movie but it's true this
movie was boring I'm gonna give The
Hunger Games Mockingjay part 1 a see it
is a well acted and good-looking movie
but nothing really of Merit happens
throughout the entire runtime I'm sorry
if I had to disappoint you guys in
telling you this unfortunately but it
happens from time to time now a lot of
people have compared the Hunger Games to
battle royale if you are a fan of battle
royale there's a really awesome website
called space wolf limited com that is
selling a really great battle royale
poster and they sent me this absolutely
incredible Breaking Bad woodcarving that
I just love and I just not it's amazing
these guys are independent artists they
make 50 of each of these things and then
they're gone forever once they sell out
what's also great is they personally
plant a tree for every wooden items sold
they have new stuff like Groot from
guardians of the galaxy
they have Doctor Who material these guys
are so so cool from now until the end of
the year you guys can get 25% off their
stuff if you enter the coupon code
stuckman when you make a purchase these
guys are super nice to me they're
offering to sponsor my videos which
helps me pay the bills so thank you very
much guys for visiting space wolf
limited comm and seeing if there's
anything there you want that's 25% off
coupon code stuckman so guys definitely
check that out I really appreciate it
and thank you so much for watching I'll
be back soon with reviews for Assassin's
Creed unity super smash for the Wii U
and a little movie called bad turn worse
thanks so much as always guys and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stubborn eyes